so let's say we have a sheep and it is
hungry so that is my sheep my best quick
drawing of a sheep and it is just
following the grass wherever it finds
good grass to eat and so in pursuit of
tasty grass it first goes ten kilometers
to the east ten kilometers east and then
it takes a right turn and then it goes
five kilometer south five kilometers
south and then it takes another right
turn and it goes ten kilometers west ten
kilometers west my question to you is
how far has this sheep traveled and
pause the video and see if you can
figure that out how far has that sheep
traveled all right now let's try to
answer this together and it's a little
bit of a trick question because
depending how you interpret the idea how
far something has traveled there could
actually be two valid answers here one
answer is you could say what is the
total distance traveled so let me write
this one down this is an important
concept distance traveled and this would
be the total length of its journey or
the total length of its path so the
distance traveled in this situation
would be ten kilometers plus five
kilometers plus five kilometers plus ten
kilometers plus ten kilometers which
would give us 25 kilometers that would
be 25 kilometers so some of y'all might
have said that the sheep traveled 25
kilometers if that's what you came up
with what you calculated is the total
distance traveled now some of you might
have said wait hold on a second
the Sheep was here before and that it
ends up right over here at the end of
its journey and so it's change in
position is it would have moved a net 5
kilometer south from this point to this
point would have been five kilometers
south it doesn't matter what it did
along the way what its path was at the
end of the day it ended up five
kilometres south of where it started out
and this would also be a valid way of
saying how far it traveled and this
notion is known as displacement so the
displacement would be in this kit
situation five kilometres south so pause
this video what do you think is the
definition or the difference between
saying the distance something traveled
versus its displacement well as we
mentioned the distance something travels
is the entire length of its journey it's
a the the entire path and this thing
will never be negative you could travel
zero kilometers but as long as you are
you are your position keeps changing
this thing will only increase because
it's the total length of your path your
displacement is your change in position
and since it's a change in position not
only will we mention the five kilometers
we'll say in what direction the position
of the sheep has changed five kilometers
to the south so let me write this down
this is total length of path total
length of path is the distance traveled
while the displacement is the change in
position change in position